j'ai la tentation de ne pas vouloir
commenter la stratégie de défense de
monsieur kraz donc je comprends
néanmoins les objectifs cela étant la
présence de monsieur kraz les conditions
de sa présence est également de son
armement j'anticipe une autre question
peut-être ont fait l'objet d'une enquête
judiciaire
je vois que je ne peux pas m'étendre
j'ai été auditionné dans ce cadre et sur
laquelle d'ailleurs nous ne vous
interrogeons nullement car ce n'est pas
notre mission et je l'aï vécu comme ça
mais chaque résident et nous avons
fourni à la justice tous les éléments
qui démontrent que monsieur vincent kraz
n'était en aucun cas et sous aucune
forme
mobilisés par la présidence de
république le 1er mai 2018 pour une
quelconque mission
je ne sais pas quoi d'ailleurs tuera
contrescarpe après les raisons
objectives qui qui démontre
sans autre besoin de preuves que
monsieur vincent crâne ne pouvait pas
être mobilisés par convoi militaire au
1er mai sur la contrescarpe il y en a
aussi beaucoup calais faire monsieur
vincent kraz à l'extérieur du palais de
l'elysée sur ordre du commandant
militaire du maintien de l'ordre
écoutez appartiendra à la justice de
trancher et tout mais vous comprenez
bien que la présidence de république
comme dans toute autre unité organique
de la gendarmerie ou désarmés qui
utilisaient réserve on ne commande pas
les gens au petit bonheur la chance
par sms ou par téléphone alors demandé
tiens si vous êtes libres demain
pourquoi passeur et vous pas faire une
joie et de réserve ici ou là non on a
des procédures de convocation elles sont
officialisés elles font toutes l'objet
d'un message
bien sûr que nous sommes amenés à être
souple avec les réservistes se comme je
voulais dit ce sont des citoyens qui
donnent de leur temps libre
mais en aucun cas nous nous travaillons
au doigt mouillé et en aucun cas on ne
convoque des gens pour des missions qui
nous rappellent sûrement rien à voir
avec le coeur du métier pour acter ils
ont été reportés ils ont été recrutés